for nearly 50 years this Lower Manhattan
skyscraper was an office building but in
a few months it will reopen as a luxury
apartment complex with 588 units but
unlike this building 1 billion square
feet of office space still sits vacant
across the country that's about 370
empire state buildings converting all
this empty space to housing might seem
like a straightforward solution to the
country's housing shortage but
transforming Office Buildings isn't
simple or cheap it's like a putting a
puzzle together we'll explore what it
actually takes to convert an office into
housing and if that could be a solution
for the vast amounts of empty real
estate becoming a crisis for cities
around the country
let's head back to 160 Water Street
located in the heart of Manhattan's
Financial District once completed the
building's Lobby will transform from
this to this developers say these types
of conversions can cost as much as 500
per square foot six new floors are also
being added to the 24-story structure
including 500 000 square feet of
apartments and amenity space
in many cities zoning laws can prevent
conversions like this one from happening
altogether the city might say well we
don't want residential buildings in that
District that's our office District
we're trying to preserve jobs and
therefore we're not going to give you
the zoning permits that you need to do
the conversion and even with the right
zoning other design challenges can get
are laid out differently than
residential spaces they might have
structural columns every 30 feet which
can make it difficult to install
Plumbing or there might be windows that
don't open developers say converting
older buildings tends to be much easier
when you think about how the design of
office building evolved during the 20th
century in the early part of the century
you had much smaller buildings they
weren't as wide in the days before air
conditioning offices needed functioning
windows for ventilation on hot days and
to light up workspaces these types of
buildings tend to have a similar design
a slim shape narrow floor plan and
punched in Windows looking up from the
sidewalk here's one in New York and
another in Chicago developers say these
floor plans translate well to Apartments
because interior spaces tend to be no
more than 30 feet from a window that
opens and with that it actually helps
out so that the units can be laid out
with the proper light and air Joey is
managing director of Van Barton group
the developer of 160 Water Street the
building conversion we saw earlier the
office first opened in the 1970s
post-war buildings like this one can be
harder to convert to housing after World
War II and the modernization of office
building construction you had air
conditioning you had fluorescent
lighting so you could get much bigger
floors and so you wouldn't have the same
access to light and air that you had in
an apartment building or in the older
Office Buildings but they were much more
efficient for landlords and much more
efficient for tenants but developers and
Architects say that setup isn't ideal
for apartment living you think about a
floor that big
how could you carve that up into
Apartments you'd have to have some very
very narrow apartments or you'd have to
have apartments in the middle which
who'd want to live there who'd want to
live in the middle of a big floor plate
with no windows you can see the
differences When comparing the floor
plans of 160 Water Street to this
pre-war skyscraper example for
perspective here's what a 600 square
foot apartment looks like in both
buildings as you can see larger floor
plans can make it difficult to construct
apartments with enough access to light
and air to solve for this the developers
at 160 Water Street are scooping out
three shafts from the center of the
building the floor plate depth was
actually a little too deep so we cut out
a series of three shafts we took that
square footage and then we reallocated
it into other areas of the building
where it would be usable square footage
and rentable square footage to account
for the additional floors the structure
is being reinforced with steel plate on
each column beams and diagonal bracing
it's also getting larger windows that
open
other buildings with large floor plates
may take a slightly different approach
like this building right next door 180
Water Street you cut out the floor and
create a light well to get lightened air
on the inside that means more Apartments
can be constructed in the center of the
building in including Studios with
Windows facing into the courtyard
for 160 Water Street the changes
resulted in almost 600 apartments with
rents ranging from 3 500 up to 7 500.
despite the lack of affordable housing
in Manhattan many conversions create
market rate Luxury Rentals according to
developers that's because it's hard to
cover the costs of conversion while
producing affordable housing for lower
income residents these projects are very
expensive and they just don't pencil out
without some kind of tax benefits what
happens in a lot of cities as a
requirement for developers to get those
subsidies and incentives they have to
provide a certain amount of affordable
units in Chicago the city is using a mix
of tax incentives and Public Funding to
help Finance several office conversions
in a vacant business district all told
the plan would lead to about 1600 new
apartments 600 of them affordable
lawmakers in cities like San Francisco
and Washington DC are exploring similar
plans to add housing and Revitalize
their office districts still initiatives
like these only address a fraction of
the country's affordable housing needs
in 2021 the U.S faced a deficit of more
than 7.3 million affordable homes for
low-income renters according to the
National low-income housing coalition
despite the challenges there are more
than 2 600 Office Buildings across the
U.S that developers might view as
candidates for residential conversion
according to real estate analytics firm
co-star to help make converting offices
more cost effective developers say
cities could create more economic
incentives like tax abatements and
subsidy programs some cities are getting
so upset about the economic impact of
empty office space is that they are
providing incentives more and more we
must make it easier to convert office
builders in New York mayor Eric Adams
proposed extending the relaxed zoning
rules that made 160 Water Street
possible changes like these could help
increase the rate of office conversions
which have seen an uptick in recent
years in 2020 and 2021 alone more than
11 000 Apartments were created in
buildings that once housed offices a 43
increase from from pre-pandemic levels
that's according to a recent study by
Real Estate research firm rent Cafe
conversions may also become easier as
Market factors push developers to sell
their least profitable Office Buildings
at steep discounts sellers have this
idea in their heads about what their
buildings are worth and they don't want
to sell it for 20 30 40 50 percent lower
than that but that's starting to happen
they have to pay the mortgage their
creditors are getting involved and once
that begins to happen then more and more
of these projects can take place foreign